uh ancho jack thanks for two great
presentations so this was a really fun
session uh there's lots of different
questions i'm sure the audience will
will have questions let me just sort of
get it started um and then i've also got
the questions that you guys fed me that
you're interested in asking each other
let me just start with
this morning we had a session on
interpretability in physics
and this afternoon we're doing
interpretability in biology and it seems
like one of the key differences is that
in physics we usually have this very
strong regularizer
which is like theory and math
and because of that especially
historically we could learn from quite
small sample size
and even perhaps many modern experiments
in physics still have what you might
think of as modest sample size or they
know how as we saw in one of the talks
this morning they know how to put the
sample size
exactly in the small region of space
that they're interested in doing the
modeling that seems to me this is a key
difference between biology as a natural
science so
you guys have
very complex phenomena you probably
don't have a strong theory my guess is
there's maybe a little stronger theory
in genetics
perhaps than there is in brain science
at this stage of the game
but you're grappling with
high dimensional spaces
uh modest amounts of samples now it
seemed like on trolls somehow had more
data
than i would have anticipated which was
nice jack you still
seem to be suffering despite the fact
that your data sets are large you're
still suffering in the lower sample size
regime where you can barely fit some of
these complex models
i was just wondering how you could
talk about the difference you think in
the challenges of interpretability
in your sciences in in biological
sciences say in contrast to physical
sciences which i realize you're not
physicists um but
but in this sort of absence of strong
theory where you're more data driven
um what are the sort of challenges this
is creating for you
actually you want to go first
uh you can go ahead i can relax oh you
think i have an opinion about this
uh um
i kind of alluded the difference between
like classical physics and astrophysics
in in my talk and i think that's related
you know if
um
you know in classical physics where
everything kind of sums together and you
know
you can you can do that there may be
issues like linking across dramatically
different measurement scales but within
a measurement scale you can kind of make
a coherent model yeah that's that's a
great place to be and um i think for
neuroscience you know we're more like
astrophysics where
we don't even know what questions to ask
in a lot of cases and um
you know the way if you kind of look at
the history of astrophysics well you
start with some you know let's just look
at the planets first
let's figure out orbit okay there are
there you know or there are there are
five classes of stars you know it's like
it's a very it's a very kind of course
to find kind of uh enterprise and i
think that's
that's the
situation for neuroscience as well
um
the problem is our system is very very
non-stationary so
dealing dealing with um dealing with a
very nonlinear non-stationary system
where
almost any experiment you could do is
going to give you a result that's going
to differ from the natural world just
ends up being a really hard problem
so um
i don't really have any great insights
about this i
though i did find it interesting however
that the very first talk today by
michelle was basically he was he was
towing the same line i i was i thought
um he was basically saying i'm really
data limited although it wasn't clear to
me how he's data limited compared to me
but he was arguing i'm very data limited
and in this data limited regime
the deep learning is not that useful
and basically you know you can you can
hijack parts of it to help your glm but
basically you're just going to be doing
the general linear model and i i feel
the same way for our data
you want to take a stab at it or
yeah so um let me start with the with
the data piece and then i'll i'll try to
address the the connection between like
the physics strategy of modeling data
versus the machine learning one um so we
have a lot of data sets but individually
each of our data sets are actually quite
small so like the genome is very large
it's three billion positions so it might
seem like there's a lot of
observations but actually these for
example these protein dna binding events
are showing
most of them have about you know 2 000
to 5000 to maximum 20 000
uh positions where they actually bind
the genome so it's it's actually
you know there's a lot of background dna
where nothing happens so there's
contrastive negative data but the actual
positive data where things are happening
is pretty small lucky for us
i think the actual function we're trying
to model is not hyper complicated so
we have small neural networks and linear
models have been doing very well for a
long time
biophysics has dominated this area for a
very long time
when it was much more difficult to
actually
measure
all of these molecule events in vivo you
know in cells in the genome
and so
i think what's happening is actually
we're going the the other way around
which is
um like i said
there have been beautiful biophysics
models that
encapsulate how proteins buy naked dna
and they can make tremendous predictions
right
the problem is uh when people start
moving from those models in these nice
isolated systems to what's happening in
the cell which is there's tons of other
stuff happening
um they're trying to build models bottom
up right so they're trying to build
um insulated models of proteins binding
naked dna and then they add
cooperativity and then they add you know
other components in the system and very
soon the physics gets
very complicated right and and it's very
hard to model it explicitly
so we sort of taking the opposite
approach now let's just take a black box
fit a neural net and then we'll try to
marginalize all the physics because like
if you look at individual components in
that
uh you would hope that if the network
can accurately predict these signals
right it must have learned something
right some physics in there and that's
actually what we observe so for example
if you take our models which are trained
on in vivo data where all kinds of stuff
is happening right there's
there's multiple proteins they're
cooperating there's kinetics there's
chromatin
uh there's concentration effects
the model has learned some version of
that now if we take that model and we
literally take synthetic sequences small
sequences
and we just marginalize our over large
number of backgrounds just to consider
the effect of that small little sequence
the predictions of the neural network
correlate ridiculously well with like
actual in vitro measurements of binding
energies of proteins to dna which is
fascinating like i mean it's it's
encoded in the data it's just some part
of it right and you just have to find a
good way to marginalize it out luckily
you know our inputs are very discreet
they're simple sequences so
marginalizing is not hard we it's just
four letters we can do all these kinds
of
tricks to do very simply marginalized
signals so but what's i think
interesting and exciting is i think we
can start building bridges between the
physics world like the
bottom up approach to modeling versus
this sort of more top-down approach
right and somewhere in the middle these
things will meet and hopefully maybe
build a bridge right completely
end-to-end so that that's my hope and i
think it's trying to see early signs of
that at least in
protein dna interactions protein rna
interactions and protein protein as well
and shall i i think i heard you say that
your intrinsic dimensionality is modest
yes for the problem and that the
phenomena you're trying to learn
are reasonably simple and learnable even
with simpler methods jack
in your
how many voxels do you have and you also
have a time dimension and then of course
presumably there's a very non-linear
phenomenon that you're trying to learn
so this is one of the key differences i
guess between the kind of problem on
shul's working on and the kind of
problem you're working on right what's
the dimensionality of the voxel space
and even that's kind of course well i
mean yeah the um
you know in my case you know i'm i'm i'm
like where on show what it would have
been if he's trying to solve this
problem in 1995 right
we have an mri machine it you know
there's 80 billion neurons there's 20
billion neurons in the cerebral cortex
and we have a hundred thousand voxels so
that gives you the dimensional direction
from 20 million 20 billion excuse me two
hundred thousand there's millions of
neurons in a voxel
uh and then they have this nonlinear
coupling to the metabolism which is what
we're measuring so the whole system is
extremely reduced
in fact you could argue it's amazing
that you can get anything out of that
the measurement is so bad
um
but
so we're we're already when we're met
when we're taking our measurement we're
already projecting down into a very low
dimensional subspace relative to what's
really there and and the dimensionality
of our of our data just depends on our
machine basically
and if i understand it on shul you were
able to do feature attribution in order
to select down to an even smaller
dimensional space that was important
but jack what you're having to do is
some sort of pca
clustering kind of production because
you know we're not willing to throw away
things right we don't know what's
relevant right so onshore knows what's
relevant and he's looking for something
and we have no idea what we're looking
for gotcha so so that's that's
interesting so so and also you can do
experiments
whereas you know jack you're kind of
working on the engine while it's running
right and you have very coarse external
measurements for the most part right
yeah we can make predictions and um
usually actually in my case the models
that we fit in the lab generally since
we're we're
almost always in my lab i would say 90
of the time we're collecting data under
some very rich naturalistic conditions
and the question is does the model we
build account for something somebody did
under a simpler system and um that's
usually the case because of course if
you build a more complicated model it
includes the simple cases as sort of
special cases of what it can do
and on sure the experiments you do are
critical to to the statistics that you
need for what you're doing right if if
you couldn't run the experiments
i assume you wouldn't have enough data
yeah so there are two types of actually
the three types of experiments we have
again very lucky to be in in genetics
because there is the
observational data that i just showed
you you can just look at these molecular
profiles there is natural perturbational
experiments which is genetics doing its
thing in in the human population right
so we actually
get
mutations all over the place there are
there are millions of them all over the
place and so we can leverage that and
they are at different frequencies
different effect sizes
and then with crispr now we can actually
make artificial perturbations too
so we can fill in the gaps uh your
natural variation samples sort of
extreme ends of the distribution of
perturbations
and now the cool thing is to figure out
how to use crispr screens effectively to
fill in the gap so now if you take
neural networks and you train them not
just on observational data they're
already doing pretty well but if you
couple them with actual motivational
information
they will completely i think get to
where they need to get
and jack just to close this thought out
like the astronomers you know you're in
a more observational setting
where you can
you can have them drive some
some visual toy system but otherwise you
don't really get to probe
and modify the brain in the neurons well
well there are you know
as the same pharyngeal he has genetic
mutations we have uh brain lesions i
mean there's tons of brain lesion data
out there uh and you know over the past
20 years the neurology community has
done a great job of building up these
databases that show you know
statistically like you know if you have
a certain spectrum of behavioral
deficits what part of the brain is
lesioned associated with that
the problem you have is that the the
assays the behavioral assays are usually
pretty simple and low dimensional
and a lot of times people have brain
disorders that they that are they don't
recognize or can't diagnose for a long
time for example just take one example
alzheimer's disease is oftentimes first
noticed by the person who has it
because they can't uh drive anymore they
can't navigate in a city that they know
well which is one of the reasons we set
up this navigation experiment
um
whereas if you go into the clinic that
won't be detected because that's not
part of the clinical acid
so so there are these brain lesions um
one i just wanted to mention one thing
that i forgot to mention during the talk
weirdly you know there was a bunch of
discussion yesterday about causality we
all like to think about causality
neurophysiologists almost never think
about causality and the the reason is
it's kind of pointless um
most brain lesions
they don't have any specific effects
they just make you kind of suck slightly
at everything and that's because you
know you've got a lesion of some small
region in a network that's highly
interconnected and so there are all
these roots around that brain area that
can kind of compensate for it and so
unless you get a lesion in a hub or some
central like you know
core area that like all the information
is flowing through it doesn't have very
big effects so it ends up being this
very complicated kind of network
uh
network science problem that we can't
really solve right now
you want to go back to what anchor said
about you have the deep learning high
level you have the biophysics model at
the cellular level
can you speculate how you will bridge
the gap does like deep learning
distillation will help you and with some
what constraints if you want to do a
distillation from deep learning model
which is very successful what would be
the first step what uh inspiration you
take from these biophysics models to do
that step
yeah that's a great question so
i can tell you sort of what we're
currently planning to do and what we're
hoping to move towards
um
you know the
uh in vitro experiments are phenomenal
and you can really
uh traverse the entire space of sequence
complexity
in a in sort of a isolated system right
but even in that case like imagine
you're more you're trying to model
sequences of size you know
even
40 right just 40 bases
you couldn't possibly generate a library
of all possible sequences
now what we find is
a neural network that's trained on in
vivo data like i showed you like in
cells in the genome
um
once you
marginalize out the component you're
interested in
right you can recalibrate it to an in
vitro experiment that measures the same
quantity you're trying to marginalize
out
and it can be a pretty small experiment
it can be several thousand sequences
and once you've done that you calibrated
the neural network to now be able to
predict
these actual biophysical quantities and
now you can generate millions and
millions of
of examples right because you can
traverse the entire sequence space in
circle and then you can fit
complicated physics models because now
you have a lot more data you you can
traverse the entire space much more
effectively
and so this there's going to be an
interesting i think feedback back and
forth where
you collect a bunch of nvivo data you're
restricted to the regime of the genome
what you see right so your sequence
coverage is pretty low
you can use in vitro data to fill in the
gaps to recalibrate
but then you can take those same neural
networks and use them as generators to
generate a lot more data to to sort of
again active learn the best experiments
to perform next and so to me the neural
network is is not just
like a black box you know predictor it
is a
it's a it's a it's a component an
interesting feedback loop where we can
now use it to design
experiments um all kinds of experiments
and they bring links between different
experimental technologies as well so i
think that's pretty exciting and i think
it's going to power
a lot of improvements in biophysical
models too which have been suffering due
to being stuck in
isolated systems and not having enough
data to scale up as you add components
piece by piece
of somebody
can you repeat that sorry
you have a success story already or
somebody did it for this approach
uh yeah we've been doing this uh very
simple we've done this um for individual
the same kind of experiments i was
showing you today protein dna binding
but we've been able to link up in vitro
and new experiments and it's really
exciting and we've been able to do this
for
proteins all the way from east to humans
to very complicated systems
and it seems to be holding so
um i think it's the first sign
that there is signal there there's
biophysical signal in the neural
networks we still don't know exactly how
to
you know model cooperativity and all of
that stuff but it clearly provides a new
framework to be able to generate lots of
data in silico by coupling in vivo in
vitro experiments with neural networks
to fill in the gap
um so
hopefully lots more exciting things to
come
great
yeah jack
i i wanted to ask you a bit more about
uh not having enough data uh because you
said it i think in some different ways
uh one of them is so basically i want to
know do we not have enough data
or do we not have the data of the right
kind
or do we not have the right
representation of the data so which seem
to be quite different things right
some of the things that you said about
the dimensionality like fourth
dimensionality which kind of makes us
lose all the information about many
relevant brain oscillations seem to
indicate that we don't have the data of
the right type
but might also indicate that we don't
have the right representation so maybe
there are certain type of
representations that are temporarily
based that we just don't even know about
so
each which type of the so all types all
of them we don't have all of them so do
you think
machine learning techniques can help us
uh make headways along this second and
uh
representation discovery oh the
representation sure yeah um
uh
you know the fundamentally we don't have
enough space right we don't have enough
space resolution
because either in in neuroscience right
now you can either get incredibly high
spatial resolution a really limited
range field of coverage or course
representation over a large field of
coverage but of course what you want is
both you want a large field of coverage
with a lot higher resolution we don't
have that
you can't get good time if you want
functional signals
with good time resolution you need to do
neurophysiology in
either extra intracellular if you do
calcium imaging which is the standard
method used if you want to record from
say a thousand neurons
you also don't have any resolution over
a second better than a second because
the calcium indicators are very slow
um mri is very slow so you we have time
problems
besides just the time resolution we have
time scale problems if the system is
non-linear and adapting you need to
record from it for a long period of time
to have it transit through its different
states and nobody does that
and then we have
i would say
an environment problem where you know an
individual experiment will be under one
local environment but
nobody has the capacity to to probe the
brain under a wide variety of different
environmental conditions which you need
to do to characterize this nonlinear
system so that's like that's all
measurement if you know once you don't
measure it it's just not in there and
it's just gone forever and you're just
screwed
based on what you have i agree you
should be able to use machine learning
to get at those issues
i would say up to now
there have been no cases that i can
think i just want to make sure i'm
really saying something that's true
there's no cases that i can that i'm
aware of or that i can remember my poor
memory skills um where somebody has used
machine learning to discover a new
representation that wasn't already kind
of expected to be there in the brain
somewhere
um but i think
it should be that should be doable
and uh the obvious way to do it we do
something like we have done where you
know you take a large number of feature
spaces that essentially instantiate
every hypothesis about representation
that anybody's ever had and then in
parallel with that you train a network
in the same task and then take features
out of that and you know
adjudicate between those two it should
be doable it's just nobody's gotten to
that stage yet and i guess that could be
a problem of explanation which is maybe
in some cases the neural nets have
learned some representation
that's novel but of course we don't have
a way of pulling it out of the neural
net yeah right yeah but but the first
step on that is just to show that
there's variance accounted for by the
neural net that's not accounted for by
by your models and then and then after
that you know you've got to parcel that
variance out and try to try to attribute
it the same as anshul has to do right
what what is causing this what is what
is it
what is it representing what information
is there i mean i'm i kind of
focus on on your story about the use of
the
the
neural network that's already trained
the alex neural network so it seems that
there is here a phenomenon of some kind
of a foundational
learning like that
there is transfer learning you do have
lots of tasks yeah you may not have
enough data for each of them separately
but they have so much in common that the
neural network that you develop now
allows you to do some kind of view shot
learning
that you get a foundational model that
captures
some commonalities between many many
type of tasks and after this have been
captured although we don't explicitly
can describe the representation this
representation allows us to do some few
short learning and and save on samples i
mean that's are you are you talking
about in the brain or in that or in the
network or both yeah no i'm i'm not
trying to understand the brain i'm
talking about the nature the network
yeah yeah yeah but that's kind of my
interpretation to your story about how
you can lose use the
network that has been trained on much
much much larger image data and now
based on this you can do
get along with much less data
i absolutely agree you can view this
whole thing as kind of some transfer
learning paradigm
um and you know recently i'm sure you
guys pay attention to this you know
google and uh uh open but it's open mind
and um
open ai there you go as you know they're
training networks that perform play like
a hundred video games right um and so
you think okay well
there was an open mind
what is that not open mind i can't
remember
in cognitive science
no open ai oh sorry
i'm senile uh open ai right um
uh so uh you know if you have a network
that plays 100 video games you think
well okay that's gotta include that's
gotta represent a lot of features unless
it's just
you know a sum of a hundred networks
which presumably it's not um it's got to
represent a lot of features that are of
general interest and are probably
represented in our brains as well
because the environment
the statistical constraints of the
environment are far larger than people
give it credit for right we're all
living in the same environment and the
reason we see the same things is because
it's it's an incredibly strong forcing
function
the trouble is the networks that are
trained to generalize are so
huge that you can't do feature selection
from them to limit to to project onto a
limited data set so again we're we end
up getting stuck again by the fact that
our neuroscience data are so limited
if if i have you know
a thousand features to protect my
neuroscience data i can probably solve
that problem but if i have three billion
features to project on my neuroscience
data that's just i'm never gonna be able
to do that so that's the kind of problem
we have
i wanna go back to this uh data size
question that we've been talking about
for 10 minutes
um i mean you showed a graph jack where
clearly you don't have enough data to
have the accuracy you're not asymptoting
in terms of accuracy right and i'm
guessing that that means when it comes
to
interpreting what the model has learned
to explanation mapping it on the voxels
and all those sorts of things that
that's not trustworthy either right i
mean if
if you have an asymptote in terms of
accurate prediction then presumably your
explanation is also kind of twitchy and
not necessarily reliable or do you think
that in fact it's reasonable
um despite not being up on the
asymptotes now i completely agree with
you but one of the pathologies of
science is that everybody ignores that
problem and and i i'm sorry i got to go
i got to go non-linear myself here so i
had a paper once that i sent into a
journal and i said you know here's our
predictions you know we're predicting 20
of the variance and here's our mod
it came back from the journal rejected
where the reviewer said you're only
predicting 20 of the variance how why
should i believe anything you say this
is ridiculous reject this paper and i
wrote back to the editor explained no
one in the history of this journal has
ever reported predictions before never
not once there's not one paper your
journal has ever published reported
predictions only statistical
significance these are not you know what
is necessary but not sufficient but the
other
you have no idea what the other
predictions for the other papers are
they could be three percent four percent
and i'm like beating the heck out of
them and yet you're publishing papers
all the time why are you victimizing me
and the editor said
that's a very good argument your paper's
still rejected so
what we did
is this is this you want to see
dysfunction we removed all the
prediction from the paper
we
resubmitted it as a new publication same
journal it was published
dump down the paper we removed
information from the paper and it became
palatable to the reviewers and they
published it and i i view that as a very
seriously messed up thing you should you
should never
be preferring a paper with less
information right that's just bad
and we have a very similar problem when
doing machine learning in health
sciences so exactly the same sort of
thing there's no way to send in papers
yeah exactly exactly uh but natural i
want to ask you a question so you don't
seem to be as data poor
do you believe that you're up on the
asymptote for the kinds of questions
you're trying to answer right now
um
i think for the qualities we are able to
measure we are doing pretty well
uh the problem for us is there are lots
of unknowns um
and
you know most of the
uh molecular events in the cell are
affected by everything else happening in
there so
um we we're just modeling like proteins
binding dna right now as a function of
sequence so it's one small component
right um but luckily what's happening is
you know
the technology is allowing now
folks to
like measure multiple modalities
simultaneously in single cells
that's huge
we can get spatial information now about
how cells are next to each other which
is huge
uh so
i would say that our models are keeping
up with the kinds of data we're able to
get
but are we solving biology
[Music]
to whatever extent we can and we are
mostly bottlenecked by what we can
measure right
a big a big bottleneck used to be
perturbation data but now as i mentioned
with population scale sequencing and
with really high throughput crispr
screens
uh in the next five ten years that's not
going to be
a big bottleneck
either and you showed some beautiful
graphs whereas you varied the separation
um
you know you got more or less binding if
you were to just throw away the data
repeat the experiment again the same
sample size would you get essentially
the same same graphs back is it isn't
that repeatable and robust at this point
yes actually in the paper we in fact use
different technology uh
to measure binding which is much lower
resolution and we end up seeing the
exact same
same results so
yeah these these findings we're seeing
um
are actually remarkably robust and
actually i want to say a few words at
some point about robustness of models
and
uncertainty and
yeah so i can you know i can talk a
little bit about that as well at some
point do it now
okay
so you know we uh we were using these
kinds of feature attribution methods and
so forth for for a while for several
years and we were facing um very similar
problems to what
people have reported in other domains
like imaging world and so forth with
extreme instability you run the model
twice even the same data
and the attributions look completely
different
um
and we realized in eddie's in our case
two things fixed fixed it really really
well
one was um
naturally putting constraints on what we
are modeling so i showed you how we are
modeling sequence mapping to profiles at
single base resolution
the previous generation versions of
these were binary labels so we would
take the signal and we would coarse
grain
a coarse screen them and and make binary
labels on the sequence saying like this
chunk of sequence is bound that chunk or
sequence is not bound right so we have a
simple binary classification task
and
there's a ton of summarization of
information there from a sequence to a
single scalar
and there are too many solutions
to get to that scalar and neural network
picks a random one
right through pooling operations and so
forth as soon as we relax that and we
decided to not summarize the data and
just predict it as it is it's noisy but
at single base resolution
that direct mapping from sequence to
profiles base to base
gave us enough constraint that it
dramatically stabilized the models we
had to initially build feature
attribution priors and whatnot all kinds
of machinery to stabilize the models all
of that is unrequired anymore it just
works
the second thing we realized is our
attributions are very noisy we were not
seeing the nice beautiful words i showed
you today
and we realized all that is coming from
experimental bias
so what we decided to do is start
thinking like statistics statisticians
uh you know with respect to the outputs
and think like machine learning people
in terms of mapping inputs to outputs so
we basically built a
boatload of covariates
into the model itself so the model
doesn't just try to predict
profiles from sequence but also includes
a whole bunch of potential biases
uh the implicit regression of biases out
of the signal simultaneously as the
model is learning
just it's beautiful like i didn't have
time to show you this but it is
remarkable what the model learns after
you give it information
about what are potential experimental
assay biases
in the data and the neural network does
a much better job than any previous
model in regressing out those biases as
well so two things fix the problem how
are those biases entered into the model
it's not obvious to me
so we just add it as an additional
modality uh in fact we can learn the
bias from the data itself so a simple
way we learn the bias is we have these
profiles across the entire genome and
there are only twenty thousand actual
events which we can call or quite
reliably
if we fit a sequence model to the rest
of the genome right the remaining
billions of base pairs
the only thing you see there is bias
because there is no actual functional
signal of that's recruiting the proteins
at those positions so there's a huge
amount of data to learn a sequence model
that just predicts enzyme bias we can do
this on an experiment by experiment
basis for free
we take that model and we predict bias
in the actual bound regions
we just add it as an additional modality
and now we have two parts the neural
network uses right directly going from
sequence and the other is this bias so
the bias regresses out as much of the
signal as possible and the sequence
module only learns the residual and the
residual is beautiful like it you can
really infer latent patterns which you
just can't see in the data and and it
cleans up everything so that's that
those are two things that really helped
us
improve uh bias modeling and then better
objective functions and can i ask a
quick question before uh or or were you
gonna ask him questions about what he
was just talking about go ahead i'll ask
later so like how do you deal with the
gene gm polymorphism do you have that
already for changing interactions and
also dynamic right do you have
generalization to dynamic and
nonlinear interactions
yeah so um we're doing two things now to
make that happen one is uh the receptive
field of our models is still a several
kilobases we're now building chromosome
scale models so we can actually
the entire sequence of the chromosome or
the genome is seen for any event
to predict any event at any position
right so now you can really start seeing
complex interactions between loci not
just within loci which i showed you uh
you can start learning those and we are
training directly on population data not
reference genomes
uh actual population genetic data so we
have actual variation going into the
models and the models can see how
variation interacts
and lastly um we are modeling a lot of
data at single cell resolution which
gives us a lot more information about
variation not just at the genetic level
but also at the cellular level so those
things are starting to help us uh it's
still a while away but with that those
are our strategies we're currently
moving towards
uh to learn
interactions across the genome and other
kinds of variation
uh beyond um
you know across single cells for example
angela a lot of the uh great examples
you gave today um were kind of point
mutations or at least very local
mutations and um you know what we would
all like to see eventually is
uh
these methods being used to
you know better understand say autism
which you mentioned today or
schizophrenia an even more serious
problem
and those are really complicated
neurological deficits that are you know
probably either have multiple causes or
are caused by the interaction of a lot
of different
genetic
uh i don't know problems so um can you
talk a little bit about how you're going
to approach those problems it wasn't
really clear to me from your talk today
with autism and and what you think the
prospects are that machine learning
might be useful for making progress on
those diseases
yeah so i think there are two important
questions here so one is um
you know what we're exactly modeling
right now we're modeling what we call
the cis context just to see contribution
of sequence which is only a small
portion of any phenotype you see right
uh how do we model the trans environment
that is everything else that the cell is
reacting to that's not encoded in the
sequence the environmental response and
the environmental stimulus
so
the idea is to is to
is to build
larger neural networks that are
hierarchical they have a cis component
and an entire trans component right so
there's all other work going on
in our lab as well as elsewhere we've
been modeling the trans components
signaling pathways all of these aspects
right and then how they interact with
the cisco component and that allow us to
model any cell state right it's not now
one model for every assay in every cell
type it is one model for a cell which
has a cis component and a trans
component and those two components
together define any cell in any state um
so that's one component which is like
basically you have an entirely different
sort of framework for trans effects
right
um
and the second thing you said is um and
that requires you to unlook at the
genome as a whole entity right so genome
scale models um so i think cis trans
plus genome scale will take us to the
next level we can then model things like
massive inversions transversions copy
number effects like much more complex
variation that scales or
bigger regions and has big impacts you
know in the network fashion across the
entire genome right and then you also
have to account for the trans components
and together i think
that will be the next
next wave basically both are happening
simultaneously but those waves are not
connected yet
um and when they do i think we will
reach sort of even better models of
cellular response and disease
thanks andrew quick question before we
wrap up here
i was struck by the fact that you had to
create new methods of feature
attribution uh
as opposed to using some of these
existing off-the-shelf methods was that
a computational issue or is it because
the off-the-shelf methods weren't really
giving you what you needed one of the
reasons i asked is there's been a lot of
discussion uh in the hallways here
during breaks about existing feature
attribution methods of whether they're
good or bad um so i was kind of struck
by the fact that you had to create your
own
yeah i mean when when we say create our
own uh there are very minor tweaks of
existing methods right we we kind of
found the um
loopholes or at these potential problems
for example gradient-based methods have
issues with saturation right like they
don't propagate when
uh neurons are saturated and so we use
finite difference approaches eventually
somebody else like another you know
another team showed that our heuristic
approach is like an approximation of
these you know the shaft scores right we
haven't even thought of that like we
just did something heuristic that made
sense to us and it worked really well
and eventually it was shown to have some
uh interesting
relationship to to
betterly under better understood
theoretical properties of these things
um you know at the same time they're all
empirical
uh we always evaluate them um since they
are largely applied we evaluate them in
terms of how they actually perform on
huge numbers of data sets so we we have
that
thankfully capacity and amount of data
that we can test them very thoroughly
and eventually the proof of the pudding
is if we make a prediction and we can
actually go test it out in a real
experiment
then we don't care how it happened right
if if the attribution method is slightly
unstable uh but it still does a decent
job at giving us hypotheses we are okay
with it right it may not have the
theoretical guarantees but it's okay for
us for discovery so
um and like i said somehow our domain
the the data we apply these methods to
uh a lot of these these attribution
methods with slight tweaks
end up really working extremely well so
it may be the simplicity of the inputs
that we have the discrete nature and
other constraints that we have from the
measurements and the implicit causality
from sequence to
you know all of these events
uh maybe the combination of those three
things just makes small tweaks actually
work pretty well and some of the
optimizations are just based on the
architectures we have very simple
architecture so we can leverage some of
the properties
uh and we can just speed things up a lot
so it's all little tweaks it's not like
dramatically new methods
and then jack i'm going to give you the
last word here
now you were able to use sort of
standard techniques often it looked like
ts you know tc nets and pca and things
like that
but you were guided by an overall very
complex system architecture that i guess
is ultimately guided by what's already
known about brain connectivity
what are the kinds of things and this is
one of the questions you had asked about
uh what are the kinds of things that you
find lacking
in the methods that you're using
that you
would really want you know help uh and
people trying to sort of push these
things in directions that would make
them more useful for for the modeling
you're doing yeah explanation you're
doing uh
well you know i mean
right now i think the um there is still
a
real limitation in applying in
from the point of view of machine
learning and applying these deep
networks
to brain data especially in the regime
of limited data so you know nobody who
builds deep networks worries about
limited data because they're applying it
to problems where you basically have
infinite data so who cares right and so
all of the optimization algorithms all
of the way the cost functions are
implemented all the evaluation
algorithms are all kind of they don't
worry about data capacity and this
there's this whole regime of extremely
limited data that basically just nobody
goes there but that's our regime
so you know ideally what we would like
is to dispense with all of these feature
spaces just use a neural network to fit
to the data set we have and then be able
to interrogate the the neural network
the fit network and figure out what is
represented right that's ultimately what
we want to know and frankly it's you
know
i have no bias one way or the other on
what algorithm gets used to do that
but but you know again as i mentioned
when i was talking about just using the
three layer networks to fit neural data
um
these networks are very data-hungry and
we just don't have those data so that
that's i think probably from the point
of view of like what's lacking machine
learning that's that's the main problem
we have gotcha so a kind of deep
learning that can be sort of ultra
regularized to work with less data uh
and not make the model too simple it's
still like i guess model if it has to be
ultra regularized yeah
like yeah i mean that's that's the
problem right is what you know what's
noise
introducing knowledge and that's what we
could see with the physics that's uh
there's so much prior knowledge and that
allows you i mean this is the basic
trait of uh
exactly machine learning
exactly yeah
okay hey i want to thank everybody for
sticking around thanks especially to
anshul and jack i thought this was a
great session really lots of fun so so
thanks for giving us a presentation and
staying for the panel
thank you
so we'll be back tomorrow at
9 30. thanks a lot
but
bye thanks talk to you soon